state of decay is getting a sequel and  with that comes some big changes I'm  Tony and this is your sizeable GameSpot  news update speaking to IGN Undead CEO  Jeff strain said that state of decay  to's world is quote substantially larger  than the first game though he didn't go  into specifics but he did add that co-op  players will be able to split up this  time you won't be forced to stay within  a certain distance of each other strain  explained that it's advantageous to do  so in certain situations but of course  there's always strength in numbers when  facing down the zombie horde state of  decay - doesn't have a solid release  date yet but it's expected to hit Xbox  one and PC in 2017 the game was just  revealed at this year's e3 so expect  plenty of new information down the road  and to keep up with all of it you're  already in the right place